the democrats have a lot of items on
their remake america wish list they have
tax hikes a huge expansion of government
of course killing oil and gas got to do
that critical race theory
but through it all they have one
overriding priority
and that's holding on to power
now many months ago the angle told you
that the biden administration
wouldn't do anything to deter the
massive flow of migrants into the
country
until they were forced to
and it took a group of 12 000 haitians
camping out under a bridge in del rio
texas
to begin to get the democrats attention
now the scenes are so disturbing
they can't be kept from the public
there are still thousands of migrants
living in this makeshift camp the
conditions are brutal it's incredibly
hot out here and this border crisis is
only getting worse we see the shocking
scene under the del rio international
bridge thousands of migrants mostly
haitian say officials living in squalor
the hospital is at the brink of being
overwhelmed because the ems calls coming
from under the bridge just don't stop
since thursday 10 babies have been
delivered
everyone was rightly horrified by the
scenes at the kabul airport remember
just a few weeks back
and the shocking scenes you just saw
remember those are happening right here
at home
the white house knows biden's numbers
are cratering right and the reasons
aren't just limited to afghanistan and
things like high gas prices the border
is a huge part of it
so they needed to do something to turn
things around which explains why the
biden administration is suddenly
sounding tougher on the border
if you come to the united states
illegally you will be returned
your journey will not succeed
this administration
is committed to developing safe
orderly and humane pathways for
migration but this is not the way to do
it wait a second wait a second
where was that guy in february because
for eight and a half months now mayorkas
was more focused on avoiding the word
crisis
than solving this problem
and that's because they wanted to move
as many illegals into the united states
as quickly as they could
and that's because the dhs secretary and
biden's keepers actually do believe that
borders at their essence are immoral
so when they say they're against illegal
immigration that means nothing
for most of the year any time the border
issue was raised these people would punt
the question
they would say things like every
administration has its challenges on the
border or the numbers weren't really
that out of the ordinary and my personal
favorite line was oh secretary harris is
engaged in getting regular briefings
that was really reassuring
but now the fact is they know 2022 is
right around the corner and they're
facing multiple crises weighing them
down
so they need to take a political weapon
away from republicans the borders a huge
one let's face it
and of course the regime media as i'm
now calling them which had been
dutifully downplaying the border crisis
for months is now stepping up to help
burnish biden's reputation as tough on
immigration
check out this npr headline of all
places the biden administration is
fighting in court to keep a trump-era
immigration policy title 42
is not an immigration authority
but a public health authority to protect
the american public to protect
the communities along the border
and to protect the migrants themselves
but apparently it only applies to
haitians
what
now trump smartly used title 42 to keep
millions out of the country starting in
march 2020 but biden came in and he
gutted that rule exempting families and
unaccompanied children from expulsion
some adults were expelled but many were
not
now they're relying on the same
regulation again
to help them with the political
nightmare that they have on their hands
and that they themselves created but
look before you get all excited about
how many of the 12 000 haitians are
actually going to deport as of earlier
today officials say just over
300 have been removed on flights to
haiti
of course that's just a drop in the
bucket
now our own bill mollusion reported
tonight that many of those gathered
under the bridge
will in fact eventually be released into
the united states they're going to join
untold hundreds of thousands of others
who have already been released into the
interior u.s by joe biden
now after they get a few headlines about
the deportations and
stanching the political bleeding
mayorkis will return to business as
usual at the border
this entire thing
is and always has been a scam
and i also blame republicans on the hill
for not having addressed this issue in
trump's first hundred days in office
they could have
under no circumstances must they fall
for the democrats border bait and switch
here
because the implicit threat from the
dems is to let the they'll let the
border crisis continue
until republicans cave to their demands
for mass amnesty
now i want you to listen closely to this
next clip it's from open border zealot
new mexico senator ben ray lujan
the border is not open it's important
that there is also a humanitarian
response here make no mistake there's a
broken immigration system the numbers
are higher now than they have been
but it also shows the violence that
families are fleeing we need to take on
this broken immigration system in the
country but also address the root cause
of immigration
oh my god he lost me at the border's not
open
now biden's subversion of us immigration
law
is a direct assault on american
sovereignty we miss this in the
conversation
his scrapping the most effective aspects
of trump's immigration policies led
directly to this current crisis
and think about it severe economic
severe national security severe
political and health-related
consequences for american citizens
it's all on joe biden
every crime they commit every tax dollar
they consume
every disease that is spread every
cartel member that's enriched
all of it is on joe biden
which brings us to why the democrats
kept hyping that phony right wing rally
on saturday stay with me this is related
now unlike the southern border where
they denied the crisis and refused to
deploy necessary resources
somehow in washington on saturday they
deployed massive resources for a
non-existent crisis
they only found one goofball and a fur
hat to interview
he's pushing him back with an open with
an open hand he's not even moving his
hand quickly that's not assault no so
you don't think what they're doing here
he could easily
it's like a davy crockett costume party
or something i don't know what that was
of course they're never going to admit
it but pelosi and schumer were
disappointed that the crowd was so small
there was no violence the whole thing
looked absolutely ridiculous
like the rise kind of of the resistance
right at disney storm troopers and all
who knows how much money all of it cost
well not that any of these thieves care
because they've been robbing the
american people blind for so long on
programs that don't work
it's second nature to them at this point
now for much of this year
it has felt like america is being held
hostage
by an incompetent white house
fear-mongering public health officials
and radical extremists who despise us
and our values
they want us to believe that unless we
cede to their demands their rules their
edicts their orders
that we won't have any freedom or any
peace
but now they're exposed
and we know they do not care about the
average american in fact they loathe the
average american
and you know the old saying
never negotiate with hostage takers
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else